hey youtubers is Charlie and the CW just
screened the flash pilot at comic-con
legally I'm gonna do non spoilers first
then for everyone who has seen it I will
do a spoiler section with a special
warning hello to any new people if
you're just finding me for the first
time I do arrow and flash videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'm even doing special comic-con
giveaways and I'm gonna be uploading the
panel so I'll explain that at the end of
the video so flash review first I feel
like because of what this show is the
cast they picked and the creative team
behind it the trailers they posted tell
you everything you need to know up front
so actually watching the episode for the
first time doesn't reveal anything that
arrow fans or comic-book readers didn't
already know it's through and through
all the best stuff Romero but done in
the light of day with a lot more humor
that's just because baryon is a much
more positive person than Oliver Queen
and if you did see those episodes of
arrow with Grant Gustin his performance
of Barry is virtually unchanged
they haven't messed with the character
or anything it's a direct continuation
and because so much time has passed they
do deal with those gaps in time in very
creative ways if you have not seen arrow
at all I'll just say that Grant Gustin
has the perfect energy for a character
like Barry Allen he's this hyper curious
bestfriend type that makes you feel like
he will definitely be on the Justice
League someday this show is all about
his origin story so just give him a few
years and pretty soon he'll be running
laps around Superman and just to clarify
I'm not talking about Grant Gustin being
on the Justice League movie I'm talking
about the comic book version of the
flash joining the Justice League he's an
a-list member you know top tier level
powers for instance whenever he's able
to draw enough energy from the Speed
Force he can travel through time
time travel powers combined with the
ability to outrun Superman automatically
make you an alias superhero the flash we
meet in the first episode is just
starting to figure things out and put
his own version of team arrow together I
guess we can just go ahead and call them
team flash but all the supporting
characters are great that also includes
detective pretty boy played by Rick cos
net I feel like because his name is
Edward Thawne everyone's gonna go into
the episode with certain expectations
and still come out surprised they
definitely had a big wink to the camera
from the Thawne character in reference
to like a speed Easter Egg but even
knowing everything I did about the
Thawne character in the zooms I was
still pretty blown away by a couple left
turns team flash or what initially forms
as Barry support circle already
characters that you've met
for the most part especially if you
watched arrow Tom Cavanagh is Harrison
wells is the person who runs STAR Labs
he's kind of like a parental father
figure type well not really a father
figure but he's a little too old to be
one of their peers he feels more like a
Slade Wilson from arrow season one only
in that he's a mentor not like the
Deathstroke version of that character
the way they form that team is really
interesting and they're definitely a lot
of comic book Easter eggs I think that
they said that this is the most faithful
comic book adaptation of a TV show that
they've done so far way more faithful
than arrow was in season one the villain
that they used to call Barry to action
is someone you guys will really enjoy
the way they integrate the particle
accelerator explosion and all those
superpowers that are gonna be happening
on the show it totally worked for me and
visually it also looked really awesome
the big concern with a show like this is
when it makes a lot of promises in terms
of showing off superpowers you can get
really expensive like during the
Smallville era it would have cost ten
times as much but it's starting to get a
lot cheaper so expect to see lots of
really cool superpowers just based on
the strength of this episode I
definitely think we're gonna get a
season two they're not gonna make an
announcement about that anytime soon
probably not till after the first couple
of episodes air but I definitely think
it's going to happen this is actually
one of the strongest new shows that the
CW has they've already announced several
additional comic book characters coming
on the show like Robbie Amell as
firestorm and now the plus steeped
character obviously that's a villain if
you remember arrow took it pretty easy
on the comic book stuff whenever it
first started the flash on the other
hand is just diving right into the comic
book stuff and that includes arrow
crossovers right now the mid-season
finale of both shows is going to be a
two-hour crossover event like the first
half of that midseason finale is gonna
be a crossover between two shows in both
those shows and then the second half is
just gonna be the each individual show
wrapping up that plotline that just gets
me so excited for both those shows this
fall and yes I'm gonna be doing weekly
videos for the flash and arrow so now
I'm gonna talk about some of my specific
favorite moments so careful for spoilers
if you don't want to know anything oh
wait just a second okay ready everybody
here we go amongst many favorites I
think my biggest moment of joy was the
Harrison wells reveal at the end right
off the bat I'll say I'm thinking the
show is gonna use him as a flash Grant
Gustin of course being the normal Barry
Allen flash Edward Thawne being another
version of the flash so we'll have
multiple flashes not all of them will be
heroes
we'll be villains here's the thing if
they're taking a lot of plot cues from
flash rebirth think about how Geoff
Johns made the transition from a bard
thon professor zoom to the next one
hunter zolomon so let's talk about
Harrison wells there's a couple
different flashes that he could be
I think he's either gonna be the rival
inhabiting the body of max mercury he
has the ability to time travel via the
Speed Force which explains the newspaper
from the future or he's a or Barth on
the true professor zoom regardless of
which flash he is I think that Edward
Thawne detective pretty boy is gonna
become the hunter zolomon zoom they're
just gonna give him hunter zolomon story
and he's gonna be named Edward Thawne
and something really interesting about
the gorilla grodd easter-egg I know
everyone got really excited about that
the producer said that they had to
really fight to keep it in the pilot
really the network was gonna take it out
and they had a demand that it stayed
just to give us that WTF awesome moment
I don't think we're gonna see any Grodd
stuff this season but he could totally
be here in season to think of it is like
a dawn of the Planet of the Apes
situation whereby you know apes gain
intelligence via this particle
accelerator explosion ask for team flash
now that we know that Robbie Amell is
playing Caitlin snows suppose a dead
fiance Ronnie Raymond aka firestorm I'm
wondering if they're still gonna drive
her to the dark side like her comic book
persona killer frost something huge
would have to happen between her and
firestorm for her to completely leave
the team
Robbie Mel's character is debuting in
the fourth episode and yes they are
doing the Martin Stein think he's gonna
be a character on the show that we'll
meet eventually no word on what that
firestorm costumes gonna look like they
might reveal at a Comic Con if they do
all included it in one of my videos but
expect it to look like a modified
version of the one in the comics just
like grant gustin's flash costume the
probably dig some STAR Labs tech out to
help contain his firestorm powers
whenever he activates them so now let's
talk about that newspaper everyone was
freaking out about at the end I think
that is going to inform the major arc of
season 1 eventually team flash is gonna
learn what's going on with Harrison
wells the time-travel stuff and what
he's trying to do and then deal with it
so here's my crackpot theory about that
newspaper so in it it says flash
disappears what if Harrison wells is the
flash that disappeared and he just
disappeared to the past the reason I
don't think that's the case is because
Harrison wells had worked at STAR Labs
for a long time as like a brilliant
particle physicist and Barry Allen as
smart as he is is not a particle
physicist
Harrison wells has to be someone else
but I do think that he's trying to
affect a future outcome by changing the
past all flash stories become
time-travel stories at a certain point
but let me know what your favorite
moment was in the comments below or if
you haven't seen it yet just let me know
what you're looking forward to and
here's the details on all the comic-con
stuff that's happening in the panels in
my giveaways so the flash is not doing a
separate panel on its own Saturday night
in Hall H Stephen Amell is doing a super
mega DC TV show panel that includes the
cast of the flash Gotham Constantine and
of course arrow arrows also doing its
separate own panel on Friday I will be
recording both of those and posting
footage so be sure to subscribe to get
all that stuff because Marvel's panel is
also on Saturday night I'll be uploading
that first just because it's winning my
straw poll but I should have flash and
arrow stuff uploaded by midnight
Saturday
I'll also be live tweeting during those
if you want to follow me on social there
are links for that at the bottom of the
description and yes I will be posting
reviews for Constantine episode 1 and
Gotham episode 1 this weekend my flash
and arrow giveaways are pretty simple
I'm giving away Funko pop arrow and
flash figures I'll pick two random
people from the comments next week all
you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so I'm gonna be posting a whole
lot of Comic Con videos this weekend I'm
gonna be adding them to a special Comic
Con playlist on my channel you can click
here to watch the first one it's my
Marvel Universe Comic Con preview and
you can click here to learn all about
Ravi Mills firestorm character on the
flash thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys this weekend high
fives
you